hey hulu fans it's max mingler and
bradley whitford from the hulu original
series the hampton bays tale
stresses are at an all-time high in
gilead and let's just say you don't want
to miss season five
stay tuned to see what else is coming to
hulu this month
i want her to know that it was me
the handmaid killing her commander
i think they'll be able to let that
stand
i'm going i'm going with you
just needs like a mom's night out i am
turned on to dance
i love it
you have no idea how iconic this is
season two here we come let's go
i'm wells adams buckle up for a brand
new saucy competition
[Music]
i had wished that it would be a little
more creative
could watch this all day long
jim will preach and i'll sing
mr phil a pleasure now god has a voice
in this fight
who's he fighting
[Music]
everybody
the devil's coming for me tammy can we
talk about satan later june
steve is a patient of aids you need to
get her under control i built you an
empire i built you an empire
one of us has lied
let us let god decide
[Music]
i say before all of you
i spoke the truth
[Music]
i want to show the people at gotham
their city doesn't belong to the
criminals and the corrupt
he's here the batman
and here we
go
this city deserves a better glass of
criminal and i'm going to give it
you either die a hero
or you live long enough to see yourself
become the villain
you can come from wherever you are
and you will find your people
[Applause]
here in new york there is this culture
okay where do we begin
buenos dias what's happening we are
speaking more spanish because that is
our heritage oh
that's french mucho is not french
demon clark fbi and the fact that i'm
here should scare the hell out of you
i'm not 25 if i want a real career i
gotta shine right out the gate
[Music]
these new keys i made must be too thick
i blame the locks honestly what if we
take this time to have a heartfelt
discussion about what we're excited
about in the new year nope
my dad kept telling me we're not going
to give up i put up about 3 000 posters
all over new york i felt in my heart
that she was out there
[Music]
they wanted to pursue bin laden through
his career network those were the
longest 40 minutes of any of our lives
i'm not gonna let anything happen to my
son
i have some bad news
we are the first family of country music
protective legacy no matter what happens
this family's been hanging on to a lot
of secrets
my god what did you do mama you are
scared the truth
lego masters is back got a few new
bricks up my sleeve
so that worked
boom boom time
[Music]
you